hello Conan O'Brien here welcome to
serious jibber-jabber
I'm sitting here with poet surprise
winning author a Scott Berg whose latest
book Wilson is about the life of the
28th President of the United States
Woodrow Wilson thanks for being here
Scott thank you for having me you're a
fan obviously of Woodrow Wilson there's
a lot to respect there I get the sense
he's not in the pantheon at the moment
your book may change that why is he not
I think he's not at the moment for a
couple of reasons the first is and and
indeed I should say for decades he was
in the pantheon I mean it was generally
Washington and Lincoln and Jefferson and
then Woodrow Wilson and maybe Franklin
Roosevelt would before him fine duking
it out but I think part of it has to do
with a hundred years later Wilson had
views on race which a hundred years ago
were fairly centrist but when we look at
him today he was he was a racist and an
Isetta geisha NIST he thought for very
good reasons
he was a segregationist but when you
look at them today I think they bring
him down several pegs in the polls of
historians about greatness now how many
of his racial views stem from the fact
that he you know he's a he's a he's a
child of the Civil War he grows up
during the Civil War in the south and
his parents have strong racial views so
does is that where it all comes from
well that's that's certainly a great
part of it I mean he was born in 1856 in
Virginia and he was raised in four
states of the Confederate States of
America right he remembered the World
War of the Civil War rather he carried
that trauma really of the war with him
he actually looked into the eyes of of
Robert E league once as a little boy his
first memory was hearing that Lincoln
got elected and that there was going to
be a war now all that being said he grew
up in the segregated south those were
the values he knew
and I hasten dad Wilson Wilson didn't
hate african-americans he wasn't a
virulent racist he was somebody who when
he became president really understood
the South and even though he had
integration in his mind he just knew the
country couldn't accept it then or
that's what he felt anyway
he predicted didn't he he predicted that
that african-americans there would be
racial integration but he said he said
it was going to take a certain number of
years and I can't remember what it was
but it actually works out almost day and
date yes yes he said it'll take a
generation or two and if you pull out
your calendar he got it almost to the
Monday that it would happen he he
again knew that the southerners
especially were not ready to embrace
this there were plenty of people he knew
who fought in the civil war or who
remembered the war as he did and he just
figured it was going to take that
generation to die and probably the one
after that before they could start to
accept resocialize invasive or during
the way life was run certainly in the
south so it's a little with Wilson when
it comes to race it's a little bit of a
paternalistic view I know it's best I
know it's best and this is going to take
time which you could see some people
quibbling with like force the issue more
I think Teddy Roosevelt got some he got
a lot of flack for it but history has
been very kind to him because he invited
Booker T Washington to dinner at the
White House
now of course reflects very well on
Teddy Roosevelt people forget that after
Roosevelt did that he didn't do it again
that's correct he learned his lesson and
I mean America made it clear don't do
that I don't do that again
and Wilson I should say also always had
the door open to African Americans I
mean he didn't have them to dinner right
but indeed the Oval Office was always
open he was always interested in hearing
from the most important african-american
leaders which he did and I remember
being really intrigued by the
one african-american writer and civil
rights activist whom I respect most who
was James Weldon Johnson who I think was
far and away the best writer of them all
and he visited with Wilson a few times
and after his last visit he said I've
really got to get over my prejudice of
Woodrow Wilson he's not this virulent
racist that I thought he said I'm not
sure I trust him but I hear what he's
saying and I understand what he's saying
so we're looking at the bigger picture
it's possible that when people talk
about the Pantheon or to be even more
crass who's in the top five who's in the
top eight that Woodrow Wilson has
suffered maybe because there's a
perception right or wrong that that he
was a racist yeah I think that's a big
part of it and he's certainly always in
the top eight right you know the
question is whether he's right after the
main triumvirate now you you you start
the book this is really stunning and I'd
heard other accounts of this but you
have a great description of it Wilson
going to Paris world war one is over
he's going to try and settle the peace
and this is unprecedented for an
American president to leave the country
for a long period of time six months six
months because there's no Air Force one
a quick trip let's sign an accordion
wreck UVic and then turn around and I'll
get back for dinner
this is he gets on a boat says farewell
to America and he's absent from the
continent for six months yes when he
gets to Paris it's Beatlemania plus
times ten times ten backstreet boys
whatever you want too what's pretend I
didn't say that I know you're a fan but
not me
I never be able to forget that yeah I
know you were you've been at every
concert and then you switch 98 degrees
the pandemonium that greets Woodrow
Wilson he is they compare him to Christ
everyone in Europe thinks he is here he
is this man that's ascended from the
descended from the clouds to save us
savior of the world
savior of the world and that's so
striking because his ascension to the
presidency is
is stunningly fast and and accelerated
he's an academic he is not he's not
someone who's done his time in politics
and we can talk about other presidents
who've gone this route but from the time
that he's President of Princeton to
Governor of New Jersey briefly to the
President of the United States is very
fast and then he's in Europe and he's a
God and you think about how quickly that
all happens this is his political rise
is the most meteoric rise in American
history beyond that his rise is the
greatest in human history that had
occurred in October of 1910 Woodrow
Wilson was the president of a small
College in New Jersey Princeton
University in November of 1912 he's
elected president of the United States
yes it's just stunning in between as you
suggested there was this 18 month period
in which he was elected governor of New
Jersey he won in a landslide he
introduced the most progressive agenda
of any state in the country and suddenly
everybody in America is looking at New
Jersey because he's cleaning up the
corrupt government he kicked out the
very machine that had picked him to be
their puppet and that's really what drew
a lot of national attention and that
indeed when he became president and in
March of 1913 he inaugurated the
greatest progressive agenda the country
had seen and not only introduced items
he got them passed right so he proved to
be even though with he had an academic
background he had very sharp political
elbows and very keen political skills he
could he could get things done he could
go this is particularly interesting
today when we're looking at the
difficulties that modern presidents have
he was able to go to the hill there was
actually an office that I didn't even
know about till I read your book nobody
knows nobody knows about this office
there's a small room off the Senate
that's for the president
he would stay there regularly in this
small room working with senators to try
and get progressive legislation passed I
think no president has used it because
it's got a very tricky name it's called
the president's room and it just sits
there it doesn't roll off the top I'm
telling you there's a problem but if you
go there today it is locked you have you
have to find the man with a key can open
it first of all but he was designed
strictly for the president's use and no
president used it before or since for
its designated purpose so Wilson yeah I
think sometimes there's a feeling modern
presidents or 20th century presidents
law doesn't think it's beneath them to
go to the hill they don't want to look
like they're coming with hat in hand to
beg they don't want to look like they're
getting down rolling up their sleeves
and making a getting in the dirt and
making a deal but Wilson was willing to
do that he was a scholar mm-hmm but he
had studied American political system in
the British parliamentary system so he
was kind of an expert he was an expert
in government on however meant whirl
around the world through the years in
fact he was definitely an expert in this
and it's not just that he was willing to
come down to the Congress he was eager
to do it I often think Wilson didn't
really want to be President of the
United States he would have preferred
being Prime Minister of the United
States he'd liked that parliamentary
system and yeah you rallied the troops
which were basically already behind you
so that was a concept that he was trying
to he was trying to introduce that into
the American system beyond that though
he had really deep feelings about the
importance of transparency in American
government he wanted to humanize
especially the executive branch he
wanted people to see there's a real
person a flesh-and-blood guy who is the
president of the United States he wanted
the country to see that and he wanted
the Congress to see that so that's why
he was there often what's interesting to
me is you just brought it up so I'm
gonna talk about it one of the
prejudices maybe I've had about Wilson
is that he does he's
his father was a minister and he I
always think of him with the high collar
the dour expression yes he's a
two-dimensional black-and-white
character to me yeah it's not just
because of his time because there's this
sorrow is this humanity to Lincoln
there's this incredible energy and
excitement to Teddy Roosevelt different
presidents can crack through what
surprised me reading this book is that
Wilson is very different than I thought
he was he years of his in his youth he's
he's a little bit lost he's he's
lovesick he is a ladies man he loves the
ladies he's very passionate yeah yeah we
could talk a little bit about that we
shouldn't he was extremely emotional
also and and I think actually this goes
back to to your earliest question I
think this is this has brought him down
a few notches in historians polls also
because he hasn't been properly
humanized and we have great concepts of
of Teddy Roosevelt charging up you know
San Juan Hill and all that so they are
kind of bigger than life characters
Wilson was in fact bigger than life in
his own day since that time though we've
had to rely on on these black-and-white
photographs that I think are rather
forbidding I think part of the problem
and this is completely self-serving but
I don't think he's really had a proper
biography about him that has really
humanized him and that certainly been
been the goal in this book but all the
things you suggested he I mean he he did
love women he was I mean I read through
not hundreds but thousands of love
letters he wrote to his first wife as
they were courting and then he had a
second wife and not at the same time I
should add his his first wife dies of
Bright's disease right disease which
hidden in kidney failure yeah in the
White House after one year he was
desperately in love with her and now
here's the President of the United
States I mean this is the stuff of
novels the presence of Michael Douglas
movie he's a he's a widowed president
yeah and he there's probably some bias
there probably people that think he
should remain where lack aren't been for
the rest of his life and Wilson is not
having that and he did wear a black
armband for about a year right but he he
began courting and it's it's kind of
fascinating and there's the President of
the United States very quietly
entertaining a very attractive young
widow he was introduced to in Washington
and having private dinners with her and
and writing hundreds of passionate love
letters to her
so again oh this is so not who most
people perceive Woodrow Wilson and he
was in touch with his you know sexual
urges I would run Wilson let's talk
about that well well he had them and he
talked about them and he acted on he
wrote about them he did well he well he
would write them in in in his love
letters certainly I mean when he was
courting these women and and I have an
episode when he's courting his his
second wife actually in which he makes
advances to this woman edith bowling
gold in the back of a car and back of
the of the limousine the white house
limo and basically she rebuffs him and
she says you're gonna have to convince
me you're gonna have to come on in
another way and and bring me around and
and he does and and within a year
they're married and and he does have his
way yeah he waited it was the right
thing to do he did I was a virgin too
until about a year ago the there's also
a lot of he's very emotional and this
surprised me too
he's very emotional about the war
Woodrow Wilson to sending young men off
to war and he's he takes that
responsibility very seriously
yeah and makes a big point of when the
war has ended of visiting these battle
Fields going there and he's very
emotional about the lives that have been
lost and the fact that he sent these
boys off to die he tried to keep us out
of war for a long time but he's so you
can see that surprised me too that he is
he he seems like almost such an
eighteenth-century
figure to me before I read this book and
then I see him now is a much more
emotional
yeah he's even he's even a 21st century
figure as it turns out and I hope we can
talk about how Wilson's foreign policy
really is what we use today but you
touch on what what may be the biggest
surprise for me in putting the book
together and this be speaks how really
passionate this man was and it wasn't
just for the ladies it was he had deep
feelings about everything and again this
is where his childhood I think kicks in
remembering the Civil War growing up
there seeing the devastation to the
south and carrying that with him all his
life so when the decision came as
president to send his nation into war he
he took this very seriously and and when
he sent two million men overseas he
realized he was signing the death
warrants for many of those men and he
always copped to it the hundred thousand
American soldiers who died he carried
that with him I mean it's it's like
Lincoln I don't know another president
who felt it as deeply as Wilson did and
he gives some speeches at these
cemeteries that are just heartbreaking
in which he basically says I sent these
men to their graves and that's why we
must have a League of Nations right so
that no mother ever has to bury her son
a soldier you know that we can go on and
maybe we have fought the war to end all
wars so this was something Wilson took
personally this wasn't politics for him
now there's a perception that I had
before Wilson before I read Wilson your
book it's maybe still borne out for me
which is he can seem early on when he's
progressive news president he's he's
getting a lot of legislation passed and
he's able to compromise as his
presidency goes on and at the end of
World War one he gets this idea of the
League of Nations precursor to the
United Nations but let's have all the
countries agree we can all get together
there will never be another war we can
sign this agreement all of our
differences can be worked out and it is
not a popular idea back home with it's a
popular with some people but obviously
it's politically difficult charged with
the Republican Senate Republican Senate
does not like it they don't like
Americans hands being tied they don't
like us being connected that way within
like this umbilical cord stretching
across the ocean - and they don't like a
Democratic president who has come up
with this plan after a Democrat he won
the war right they wanted to say oh the
Republicans will win the peace right
will take care of that he'll take care
of that but that's where he seems
inflexible to me he gets this idea and
he there are many opportunities that you
can talk about him more depth where he
has a chance a chance to get this passed
and his big rival is Senator Henry Cabot
Lodge of Massachusetts and all he has to
do is there's some times where there's
have Tomica compromise and he can't do
it it's fascinating to me because we're
seeing right now one of the things that
makes this book so fascinating is that
there's a very similar scenario that's
playing out every day in the newspapers
if anyone still reads newspapers on your
computer screen or on your phone it is
playing out where some people feel that
we have an idealistic president who's
got an idea and he's not willing to
compromise and there's a lot of
dissension in the country that's
essentially where to me I still feel
that Woodrow Wilson was inflexible when
it came to the League of Nations is that
fair it's more than fair he was
completely inflexible and I think there
were a couple of things at work
the first thing goes back
to those cemeteries where he would give
these moving speeches and and basically
own those dead soldiers he was saying in
essence I owe it to these dead men to
fight for this league and they gave
their lives I will now give my life if I
have to for this uncompromised position
so that's certainly part of it the
second part I think was he he was
suffering from certain mental illnesses
along the way which is another part of
the book he was having we now realize
strokes as far back as his 30s in fact
this is what stunned me because it's
well known that he had a stroke a stroke
when he comes back to United States he's
in a deadlock with the Senate he decides
I'm gonna go and preach my case to the
people themselves he gets on a train
whistle stop tour I'm gonna go town to
town to town this is before you could
just go on television or the radio and
do it he goes town to town to town falls
ill and has a devastating stroke what I
didn't realize it comes out in your book
in his 30s he's having what he thinks
her writers cramps yep from from holding
his pen to long ago but it's accompanied
by depression and he and losing vision
and yes real depression though he would
just have what we now call break downs
yeah
and he was suffering from them but
indeed in Paris when they were
negotiating that treaty for the six
months that the president is not at home
sometimes there were days of truly
aberrant behavior there's a great scene
you talk about where he's rearranging
he's rearranging will you tell the story
but he's he's had some he's rearranging
the furniture he's insisting we all stop
and let's rearrange the furniture so
it's chromatically more pleasing that's
exactly right
yes I wanted the the purple chair
clashes with the green and let's move
all the Reds over here and I want the
British to be sitting in the blue chairs
and and it's a little manic and a little
crazy and the doctor is looking at him
he had a doctor who travelled with him
all the time who said mr. president
let's take a walk
and they come back and everything is
fine but you know now we're rearranging
the world not just rearranging subvert
ature and you begin to realize well that
he was having no doubt some episodes
some cerebral episode and you have to
wonder how many of these were happening
in other years but also we now know
strokes affect emotions and just the
body chemistry what's going on and I
think a lot of this contributed to
Wilson's inflexibility at the very end
over the League of Nations part of it
was what emotions are flowing which
humors are flowing but but part of it
too is you know when you're feeling bad
you make different decisions your time
is you're less free with your time
you've really got a husband and you've
got two you make quicker decisions and
sometimes you make wrong decisions and I
think Wilson was doing a lot of that in
the last year or two unfortunately they
have Universal consequences
we need a neurosurgeon to come in here
and and talk about this part but I got
the sense reading your book that one of
the side effects of a stroke might be
monomania or where you're just you can't
you start thinking about how this mug is
is black but not quite as black as the
table and if you're having an episode
I'm just then become obsessed with how
do I get this mug to be as dark as the
table and should we get a lighter mug or
a darker table and I can't break myself
free of that obsessive thought and
that's what it starts to feel like with
Woodrow Wilson is that he just League of
Nations League of Nations League of
Nations League of Nations League of
Nations and he can't let it go and I
will will it into existence and in fact
because he was the most religious
president we've ever had as well that it
is his mission he really did believe
that it was God's will that he be
president it was Providence he was
chosen it was all there
and indeed right after he's elected a
kind of flaky campaign manager who
worked on the campaign but got ill
himself in getting Wilson
that came to Wilson to get a political
job afterwards and Wilson greets him and
says before you say a thing you had
nothing to do with my getting elected
president this I was chosen to do this I
came from above so Wilson believed that
he really did and the amazing thing is
he didn't bring religion into his
speeches and talk very often but his
religiosity his deep spirituality really
informed and infused every decision he
ever made now the problem is that can
get dangerous if you believe that God
made you president you can also believe
that all of your decisions are God
speaking through you I went through a
phase like that unfortunately I have
good people around me who slapped me
around but stunned to hear the former
but not the like yeah but but but so
that's the question is did that in
hamper his ability at all to be the one
in the one breath you're saying he's a
very human president he's a real
full-blooded three-dimensional human
being but he also believes that God has
made him president yeah and you know
with his religiousness came actually a
strange modesty that he had I mean he
there was a humility to him he's
probably the most humble person with a
christ complex we've ever had in the
White House but he was both it's it's an
amazing juxtaposition of the two but but
he did have all that and he felt he felt
secure in his decisions yeah and I think
I think that's where I wouldn't go so
far as to say God was speaking to him
but he felt God was allowing him to say
what he had to say and that therefore
whether it was correct or not if God was
gonna have to correct it later on as he
might have to that's his business but I
am meant to do what I am meant to do and
he was always clear about it he was
always clear about what his mission was
I there's something that you've picked
up in this book that I really enjoyed
because it tells you something about him
and it's also very relatable he was a
good hater he could carry a grudge if he
was mad at someone he could really work
himself up about it and how did that
play into his presidency
yes yeah his entire life in fact and in
fact he wouldn't get worked up in too
much of a lather if somebody crossed him
the curtain came down you were just out
of his life and there are two or three
episodes of the people closest to him in
his life one when he was a college
professor and president I mean he had a
dear dear friend whom he used to see
several times a day couldn't get enough
of him but when there came to be a
crucial fight at Princeton about the
social structure of the school which
Wilson was trying to change and this
great friend Jack heben crossed him and
voted on the other side Wilson decided
never to see him or speak to him again
and really went the rest of their lives
doing that I mean there were a few
occasions in which he had to speak to
him formally but that was it and so it
was with a couple of his advisers as
well he had he had three extremely close
advisers for another house Colonel house
was one and he's one of his closest
friends and advisers with him all the
time and then when Colonel house is out
he is just out out and and when Wilson
leaves Paris where Colonel house has
been his chief negotiator Wilson says
goodbye to him at the train station
Wilson then takes the train gets on the
boat but he never saw Colonel house
again he never spoke to Colonel house
again
he called Colonel house his second
personality is you know I mean they they
were virtually inseparable
but again Wilson never saw him and then
there was another fellow in the white
house named tumult II who was sort of
Wilson's chief of staff who had come
with him from New Jersey and was an old
Paul who really ran that side of things
for Wilson but he did something after
Wilson left the White House that Wilson
disapproved of and again never saw him
again never spoke to him again
I'm curious about
his name's come up before in the
conversation with Teddy Roosevelt is you
know he's president the turn of the
century and for a good part of that
decade before before Wilson becomes
president and they're both progressives
so they both stand for a lot of the same
things and in fact Wilson gets a lot of
things passed that Teddy Roosevelt would
have loved to have gotten passed so
you'd think they'd be on the same page
yes now during the war Teddy Roosevelt
very badly wants to go and fight yeah
and he comes to he's too old to fight
but he goes to Wilson for a dispensation
please let me go
and let me fight Wilson won't give it to
him that's true and you think sometimes
I look at that episode and I've read a
lot about Teddy Roosevelt and I've read
your book down Wilson and you look at it
from both sides and it's hard not to see
some element of maybe jealousy or just
obviously Theodore Roosevelt said a lot
of nasty things about Wilson and was
probably jealous of Wilson so Wilson
this is an opportunity for Wilson maybe
who's a good hater to say I'm not gonna
give you the limelight you'd really love
to go across to Pett to France and fight
maybe even get killed and be and I'm
going to deny you that I'm gonna deny
you that's that chance in the spotlight
is that well everything you said is true
and and Teddy Roosevelt detested Wilson
oh not at first but then increasingly
yeah well once Wilson got into politics
he did yeah you know when he was a
college professor and they had met he
thought oh that's great he's a wonderful
scholar let's keep him there at
Princeton in here but once Wilson was in
the White House
everything Wilson did was wrong in Teddy
Roosevelt's and unfortunately tell you
Roosevelt was you know there's very
happy to tell anybody and his speeches
and he did and he did and he talked to
the press all the time and he basically
thought Wilson was a wuss and and had
really never left the school yard you
know he was a college guy
Wilson though proved to be so effective
and I think that
teddie result the wrong way too now to
get to the incident you were talking
about when we finally do enter World War
one basically Teddy Roosevelt wanted the
Rough Riders to write again and he
wanted to bring back his whole team and
render charge up San Juan Hill or the
version in Europe wherever that was
gonna really work against crux cannon
yes rapid fire and part of what you
suggest is true but I I give Wilson the
benefit of the doubt here that Wilson is
now the commander in chief and he has to
deal with a lot of things one of which
is do I really want this old soldier now
to be mustering his own little army yeah
and we're sending them to your end and
not only that not only is he an old
soldier but he's also a former
commander-in-chief a former primary
popular extremely popular and how will
that be for say General Pershing who is
going to be heading out right armies our
American Expeditionary Force what's that
gonna be like when he's trying to get
two million men fighting there and Teddy
Roosevelt's getting the headline every
day because he's Teddy Roosevelt right
he's riding a donkey to try and capture
the Kaiser well he's got some crazy some
semantic scheme and it's a stunt
yeah no and and at the end of the day
Wilson did think Teddy Roosevelt was a
blowhard yeah and and enough you had
your chance and now this is the way we
run the government today and it's a very
different means there's another
Roosevelt we got to bring up which is
franklin roosevelt franklin roosevelt is
gets his first big key appointment
assistant secretary of the navy exactly
right from wilson you so and that really
gives him franklin roosevelt his start
yep if you wanted to you could make the
argument franklin roosevelt never
becomes president and if it's not for
Woodrow Wilson well I I mean I could
argue that but I mean certainly this is
where his real political career begins I
think I'm certainly on a national level
right it's the first time he's getting
national coverage
he fought very hard for Wilson to get
the nominee
from the Democratic Party in 1912 he was
a great supporter in 1916 he was a huge
supporter of everything Wilson did he
really idolized Wilson he watches Wilson
I can see him almost picking up tricks
from Wilson and how to how to deal with
the press with cabinets and so forth you
know Wilson was the first president to
hold press conferences and I can see
Roosevelt seeing how Wilson was relating
to the people was writing to the press
he's picking all this stuff up
and indeed the progressivism I mean you
know Wilson had this incredibly
successful new freedom it was called we
haven't been specific about that so I
should probably
we should probably clarify Woodrow
Wilson is when he when he takes office
there's this again something we're
dealing with today there's a 1% of the
country that has an incredible amount of
power and influence and money and money
no income tax is that correct that's
correct and Woodrow Wilson comes in and
single-handedly tries to and succeeds in
getting an income tax and trying to
start to build a middle class and not
just an income tax but I graduated
income tax called us a redistribution of
wealth if you like but this was one in
which richer people would pay a greater
percentage than poorer people he lowered
the tariffs he wanted to get rid of the
tariffs because everybody had to pay the
penny on a pound of sugar well that
doesn't mean anything to a rich person
but to a poor person that extra penny
does count so things like that the
Federal Reserve System was something
Wilson brought in the eight-hour workday
workmen's compensation but the first Jew
on the Supreme Court
all these things were leveling the
playing field in America Wilson wasn't
anti rich people he wasn't auntie big
business but he was anti unfairness and
he wanted everybody to have a shot and
so if you look at everything he did in
the new freedom or indeed everything he
did as a president of Princeton he
really was trying to level things here
so FDR watched all this and he saw what
worked and what didn't work and I think
this was very much in the back of his
mind when he became president was Wilson
fond of Franklin Roosevelt or did he not
really know him that well a little above
he didn't know him all that well would
he you know because he was second-tier
he wasn't in the cabinet yeah but what
he knew he liked and he certainly knew
FDR was a great supporter he was I don't
want to call him a lap dog but he he
really loved everything Woodrow Wilson
did there were moments I felt he was
being slightly sycophantic but he was a
hard-working guy who wanted to get ahead
there's no question about it and as a
lot of people forget Franklin Roosevelt
ran for vice-president on the Democratic
ticket in 1920 with Governor Cox of Ohio
and the two of them came to visit the
Wilson white house to get Wilson's
blessing if you will and at this point
Wilson had had his stroke he was in a
wheelchair covered with blankets no one
saw him from notes down nobody saw the
president for a year and a half really
except a few people who were invited in
and and Cox and Roosevelt were invited
in and and this is just me now decades
later but I honestly do believe when I
see pictures of Franklin Roosevelt and I
see pictures of Woodrow Wilson I am sure
once FDR was stricken with polio I am
sure he flashed back to that day he met
Wilson at the White House in the
wheelchair and just the way Wilson
comported himself the way he tilted his
head up and kind of looked straight
ahead and you know know no plea for
sympathy just keep going charge-charge
how to mask a devastating illness yeah
it's interesting that I hadn't thought
of that but yeah Franklin Roosevelt is
the protege to Wilson and Wilson gives
him an example of progressive being a
progressive president but also how to be
completely stricken and hide it from
America
which is I mean people my parents are
that generation people had no idea that
that Franklin Roosevelt they understood
that he had had a problem with polio but
no one thought that he was completely
wheelchair nobody had a clue yeah there
really didn't it was in the backs of
people's minds but people didn't need to
didn't see it and the press was
complicit which we should talk about how
could Wilson be that sick I mean he was
today Wilson were president today or if
a modern president was stricken
devastating stroke that paralyzed his
left side yes paralyzed his left side
and he'd be rushed to the hospital and
he would never go back to the White
House correct he'd be relieved of his
duties almost immediately how did they
get away with it well a lot of things
were at work first of all mrs. Wilson
the second mrs. was second mrs. Wilson
yes did not tweet you know there were no
instagrams so she tried to tweet them no
one had a device yet and she yeah and
she just couldn't get it down to 140
character problems she was so wordy so
another everything you know so that was
certainly a factor that media and
communication was just very different
also the way we treated the president
was very different there was a sense of
privacy a certain element of that also
he had very good relations with the
press so they were inclined to give him
whatever distance they needed well but
we're talking a year and a half year and
a half and virtually unable for a large
chunk of time he could do no work that's
correct for a couple of months really
and his wife would go in the first lady
would go in and into a room and then
come out and say okay this is what he
wants to do nobody knows what happens
she talking to the president or a sock
puppet I know when no one knew what was
happening in that room quite right and
indeed I mean I characterize it in my
book as the greatest conspiracy that
ever fell upon the White House which is
the second mrs. will
and a handful of doctors made a decision
that they would keep the president's
stroke from the world and for a year and
a half they did pull that off and
basically every decision that had to be
made every person who needed to see the
president after a few months had to pass
through mrs. Wilson yeah and she for all
intents and purposes you know it's been
argued she became the first female
president of the United States but
indeed nobody could get past or you know
or get to the president without going
through her so it's as simple as that
and as complicated is that also I should
add the Constitution was different than
it is today we have a 25th amendment
today which which defines presidential
disability back then in 1919 when he
suffered a stroke that was not the case
and so one could happily go along and
nowhere was it written what determines
when the president is no longer able and
they figured well he can still talk he
can still think they couldn't really
measure the emotional oscillation in his
life the mood swings and whatever was
going on and their concern was his
personal Constitution not the United
States Constitution right so that being
the case they you know the doctors told
mrs. Wilson too much stress will kill
your husband so she said well then we'll
keep all stress from him right and the
way they chose to do it was to have her
be the middle person what's shocking to
me is that 1920 rolls around mm-hmm
Woodrow Wilson is thinking of running
again which is insanity
I mean he's you were talking about
someone who shouldn't have finished his
yeah should have been relieved you know
two-thirds of the way through his second
term he's considering running again and
waiting to be nominated hoping he'll be
nominated and if he is nominated you get
the sense that he would run that he's
desperately ill that he would run and
he's making lists of cabinet
birds and things he wants to run on and
this too though see this is where I
think the effects of the stroke are
kicking in that we can't measure I mean
I think there was a touch of madness
here that was that there was a euphoria
which often accompanies strokes and I
think he was not able to make proper
judgments and so here here was an
example of it we haven't talked about
also the logical question which is did
anyone think of calling the vice
president you know which might have been
a good idea I think the vice president
would drop by once in a while and and
poke him with a stick or you know well I
mean I got the sense the vice president
was not eager to be President yeah that
fair to say that's more than fair and in
fact the Vice President was Hamas our
marshal of Indiana correct
Thomas Riley Indy hey I wrote the book
for 13 years I know I got some of the
president's name want to quiz you thank
you thank you and he did show up a few
times but mrs. Wilson wouldn't let him
in vice president we're here to see if
the president's alive he's in that room
you can't see him well I'll be going
there it is it is I mean it's sad but
there's a comical aspect to it well
there are no and you have to understand
if you can believe this the office of
the vice president was considered a
comical position yeah especially unlike
today yes exactly we all have the
greatest respect for mr. Biden but but
then the vice president really did
nothing except wait for the president to
die yeah and this was a vice president
who did not want the president didn't
die he didn't want to be President he he
really didn't and I I talked to well I
talked to hey how about this I talked to
Theodore Roosevelt's daughter
the legendary Alice Roosevelt Longworth
my famous quote from her as if you don't
have something nice to say about anyone
come sit by me well I can I want to hear
it well she had a few others which well
well I knew her in my 20s and she was in
her late 80s and she I got into a
conversation there about Marshall who
she claims so I'm sure this is um
because it came from her oh that's a
good way to test any theory Roosevelt
say it had to be false but she claimed
that he had a business card that said
Thomas r Marshall vice-president of the
United States and Toastmaster which he
loved being he loved being a postmaster
right and she also told me that when
they finally did divulge the secret to
the vice president that Wilson had a
stroke that he fainted yeah so you know
this was a guy who didn't really want
the gig yeah that being said I often ask
myself because these were the same
things people said about Harry Truman in
1944 and 45 what if Thomas Marshall had
become president who knows if the light
were on him who knows but if he wouldn't
have become a Harry Truman Harry Truman
is a joke to people when he's vice
president he's I think he had won one or
two meetings with Franklin right that's
it he's the same number of failed
haberdasher that was it he was the
tailor yeah you know and now not until
he's president and then look what
happened though so that's a fair
question to raise about Thomas R
Marshall it's a fair question to ask of
Edith Wilson and and the doctors who's
to say what Marshall might have done or
not done the office can change people
can change people and who's to say that
people might have had such pity for
Wilson they might have said to President
Marshall you know what let's pass that
League of Nations yeah let's do it in
Woodrow Wilson's name who knows Woodrow
Wilson leaves the White House and in
comes his polar opposite yeah
Harding yes and Warren Harding is
immediately recognizes and tells anybody
who will listen I'm in way over my head
yes I'm a good poker player I'm fun at a
party I'm an idiot and I'm paraphrasing
yes you are but not by much but also
immediately revealed himself as immoral
and fairly corrupt yeah with a lot of
cronies and this
suddenly Woodrow Wilson's stock if it
was down a bit when he left office
people start flocking to his house he
has a beautiful house I've actually
never been there I'd like to see you go
there I want to go there the great house
people go to his house and flock outside
and applaud whenever he comes out to
take a ride in his in his car that's
driven around in a beautiful Pierce
Arrow Pierce Arrow 1919 pierce-arrow and
today still have the car the car is
actually at the Woodrow Wilson
Presidential Library in Stanton Virginia
oh it was government property no it
belonged he bought it he got his
property but he bought it right or he
had friends who bought it for him
because this was before the days of
presidential pensions and a few people
Bernard Baruch among them said this is a
disgrace so they raised some money
privately for the president for Wilson
so here Lavaca t'v of Ronald Reagan very
modeled Reagan had citizen people
powerful California businessman hey this
guy was the president let's get him a
nice house let's get him let's set him
up his his retirement if you can call it
that he's sick he's living in this home
but I was surprised when I read your
book that his retirement he lives for a
few years I always thought of him as
this figure that it's very tragic he's
off on this noble quest he falls sick he
leaves office and then fades into
darkness and I read your book he's being
driven around in this beautiful
pierce-arrow
and watching a lot of movies he loves
the movies and they're screened for him
he loves the movie stars he loves all he
watches pretty much every movie he can
get his hands on everyone and yes and he
runs out with monoi and he goes to the
theater all the time he loved his
vaudeville he loves vaudeville I mean he
goes to the vaudeville theater once or
twice a week even when he's president
when he's president in the best of
health he was sometimes hop on a train
and go up to New York to see a show you
know this is a guy loved theater he
loved movies yeah there's a sweet scene
that you described where he's watching
the he's ill and he's in retirement and
he's watching some show and all the
actors come out and greet him and
he's loved he's beloved he is truly
beloved yeah that's when he goes to the
to the vaudeville theater and and they
would all turn out I mean the actors
would go on stage and just acknowledge
his presence calling them the greatest
soldier of all you know and then they
would all flock to his limousine in the
alley afterwards as he's leaving to go
back and as you said they would turn out
to see him you know take his his
afternoon drive every day and on
occasions like Armistice Day November
11th each year there'd be a thousand
people that I'm sure there'd be 10,000
people next year 20,000 people gathering
out just to get powerful he's uh he is a
rock star here and he became this great
icon of well of idealism of peace of
freedom of all those things and and
that's why I think part of the legend
lives on and you know that's that's the
good aspect of Woodrow Wilson then that
wants examination re-examination the
stepping back and looking at the bigger
picture he's he's right he's very right
about a few things he makes it very
clear at Versailles to the European
leaders you being too tough on the
Germans you and if you extract these
kind of penalties from them you're going
to [ __ ] them as a country and it's
gonna come back to bite you in the ass
exactly what happened and you get World
War II and he said in 25 years the same
countries will all go to war get your
calendars out yeah I mean put an X on
Tuesday he got it yeah he understood
that and and there was no talking to the
French the British they were so mad
about that war and everybody had this it
becomes absurd you're reading about how
everyone's they have accountants trying
to figure out what a human life is worth
and then there's their handing a bill to
Germany and saying you owe us I don't
even know what the numbers are or what
they would be today but you know what
you owe us you know hundreds of billions
of dollars in in gold
to pay us which is an absurd idea you
can't there's no it was a tragedy all
around for everybody well it was and of
course the the rap that Wilson often
takes is that he was too hard on Germany
too onerous the bill was too great and
that that is what led to World War two
in truth the bill that Germany was
handed was something they could deal
with uh and in further truth the Germans
never paid it right so that ultimately
isn't the reason they went to war again
but Wilson did understand that about
beating them down this again goes back
to his childhood remembering because
reconstruction exactly right right and
he knew the toll it was going to exact a
generation or two lazy humiliate your
enemy then they will come back they will
they have to just human nature the other
thing that and this is the this is a
just a much bigger question that relates
to where we are today is it's a thought
that's a you know been brought up by
other people and it's occurred to me a
few times is Barack Obama and Woodrow
Wilson and possible parallels between
the two both academics both very rapid
rise yes to very rapid rise to an office
to the office of the presidency both of
them you could say idealistic as a
positive and maybe even potentially
potentially as a negative that Woodrow
Wilson had a big idea which was his his
fourteen points you know his League of
Nations and Obama has a big idea which
is health care universal health coverage
and both very married to an idea yeah
and it's their rise and also potentially
their fall is that is there do you think
it's a parallel there at all well I
think there yes I think there are every
parallel you've just named I would also
add that they were both great orators I
mean Woodrow Wilson was the greatest
orator of
of his day and is in fact the last
president who wrote all of his own
speeches and he was just an incredible
wordsmith as well as a great written how
many books before he was he'd written a
dozen book dozens books and he was
well-known famous as a historian he was
it's almost as though Arthur
Schlessinger ran for the presidency and
got elected by an electoral landslide
so that's who Woodrow Wilson was I mean
he was our most I was I won't say he was
our greatest intellectual but he was
among our most famous intellectuals
right he ran for president and in 1912
so there's there's that parallel that he
and Barack Obama are also very
persuasive when they speak so they have
that I would say Wilson I think
strangely because he was more of an
academic really knew how to play the
game a little better at least he worked
the Congress he knew how to massage them
he knew how to elbow them Obama I'm not
sure that's the case and yet I think I
think you know he's already got his
health care thing passed the Supreme
Court has passed on it and and I think
you know he's up against opposition the
likes of which who could imagine it's
just relentless so my money's on Barack
Obama on this and I think in some ways
that's highly wilsonian and I think
Obama he reminds me of Wilson a great
deal a great deal well it's also I I
remember when I think one of the first
times that Obama went to Europe and I
actually thought about Wilson because he
goes to Europe and there is a level of I
mean Osmania yeah and also the the Nobel
Peace Prize Nobel Peace Prize too soon
into his presidency there's a there's a
treatment overseas that and then you
come back home to the reality which is
the same thing that happened with
Woodrow Wilson I think Barack Obama I'm
a God when I'm in Europe and then I come
home you know why don't you know how
they treat me yeah I'm in Prague they go
crazy but but yeah then your your house
for votes in in in South Carolina yeah
yeah exactly right so great great
similarities no no question about it no
they they remind me a great deal of each
other it's possible I was talking about
with with a good friend of mine who has
the loves the same subject and we were
talking about this and he said we got
into this argument and I'm not sure what
the answer is maybe
maybe you have an idea is it possible
that America the American people are
uncomfortable with a president who's got
a big grand idea that they are more
comfortable Franklin Roosevelt is always
shucking and jiving bobbing and weaving
same with John F Kennedy
they don't marry everything to one idea
they'll move they'll change their
position Woodrow Wilson and Barack Obama
will plant their feet proclaim a big
idea and stand by it maybe sometimes to
the discomfort of the American people it
might be something inherently we're not
sure we want yeah I think I think
Americans are not by nature a
philosophical people we don't
necessarily want the big concept we want
specifics we we like things to work so
you know so for bombers well here
website health care website just worked
that would mean more to us than than the
health care law I hadn't been a
philosophical notion yeah yeah so I I
mean I think there there is genuine
truth to that though and and Wilson was
truly a man of ideas he would tell you
also a man of ideals you know and then
we've had other presidents you know who
say do you want me to talk about the
vision thing I mean a lot of presidents
just don't have the vision and don't
like talking about the vision right
that's an uncomfortable and they think
it's hokey they do
Wilson was so comfortable talking about
that and he was so comfortable he could
convince the people people bought into
it I think in large measure people
bought into Roosevelt's visions as well
and and I would say Ronald Reagan was a
man of vision yeah and and so it is
effective but you but you need the
specific programs to back
up and you need them to work so that's
enough that's another thing and Wilson's
did work so that really helped him a lot
I mean he came in not just with this
agenda but he got it past I mean there
was just one measure after another it
was just unbelievable which have changed
really changed the nature of our country
well certainly changed well domestically
economically and set up things that
Franklin Roosevelt will do that then
later on Lyndon Johnson will do that
then later on Barack Obama would so it's
a it's a there's definitely a
progression I think it really does go
back to Woodrow Wilson and indeed in
foreign policy and this this is either a
really good thing or a really bad thing
but all American foreign policy to this
minute goes back to Woodrow Wilson
leading us into World War one when he
gave a speech in April of 1917 and said
the world must be made safe for
democracy and again whether you approve
of that or not or like it or not doesn't
matter it is the bedrock on which all
American foreign policy is built what's
in one sentence we went from that's not
us we stay here isolation or
isolationists to we are no foreign
entanglements we're responsible yeah I
mean it's it's George Washington who
says let us not get entangled that's the
whole key exactly but he meant for a
period of time until we're strong enough
and Wilson reacted to that saying but we
are entangled don't you see the world's
changed it's got smaller communication
transporation it's shrunk the world what
happens in Indiana is felt in India you
know I mean so these things happen and
and Wilson's feeling was okay now that
we are entangled how are we gonna deal
with this right and this was the way he
felt it should be and again this goes
back to his religiosity he felt there
should be a moral component now to our
policy because he felt there should be a
moral component to who Americans were
and now are now yeah we have a question
from the we have an internet question
and this is at shadow of Krypton I'm
Twitter
yes that's the kind of show you're on
that shadow of Krypton asks who do you
think was the most influential president
that's a pretty that's a broad brush but
you want to take a stab at it who who
well I feel Wilson was of the 20th
century anyway
I think we have to say Washington yeah
it was because he gets the whole thing
rolling and the way he gets it rolling
and the way he deals with the presidency
and then I think you have to jump to
Lincoln and as a president basically for
the efforts to bring the keep the
country together and then to bring it
together so I also think I always I
always think that Lincoln's greatest
gift might have been he's he was our
best writer he just just I think that's
true just he's he's a poet
yeah it's actual poetry that he wrote
it's terrible but he's but his whose
yeah exactly yeah but but his his his
prose was his words just you know I was
at an event recently and someone read
the Gettysburg Address and I'm crying
it's it's good writing yeah and I
wouldn't dismiss Thomas Jefferson as as
a writer now you know I mean we've had
some really amazing thinkers and writers
in the White House many more who were
not and many more who simply didn't
write yeah as I suggested Wilson is the
last to write all his own material
including some magnificent speeches and
not only did he write them
he was the best to Nara in the White
House he learned shorthand when he was a
teenager so he would write the first
drafts in shorthand and then he'd sit at
a typewriter and type them up himself
and it's just crazy to think of a
president mr. president hold on you know
I'll be there in a minute I'm finishing
this speech that that will change the
world
yeah that will change the world we're so
divorced from the idea that someone
would write their own speech but he he
literally did though
yeah I mean I mean these major speeches
and most of his speeches he didn't write
he was such an
credible extemporaneous speaker he would
go out to campaign with a note card with
five bullet points on it
and he could talk for an hour and a half
and somebody would then transcribe it
and well I've gone through the
transcriptions there's not a word out of
place there's not a syntactical error
there's not a paragraph that doesn't
follow its predecessor he was just he
was magical really magical and he had a
wonderful voice well you've done a great
job I have to tell you I'm like I you
when I saw that this book was coming out
as excited to read it and you've really
changed my thinking a lot about about
Wilson I don't know I don't know where I
put him in the list yet I still
Lincoln's number one for me deservedly
and then Chester a Arthur of course now
Van Buren
don't forget Fillmore Fillmore the
second George Bush I have my own list
yeah which may not correspond to your
list at home I like saying at home and
we're on the internet your problem I
don't know you're watching this this is
our box yeah exactly
this is this was really fun for me I I
hope that if you've had half as much fun
as I've had then I'd been a terrible
host but thank you so much thank you
really if that happens great yeah thanks
so much for doing this and the book is
is Wilson a Scott Berg and you should
get this book it's fantastic and this is
Conan O'Brien this has been another
serious jibber-jabber do I say anything
at the end I can't remember like press
ctrl alt 7 and stay away from the
pornography because it's fun but
ultimately damaging peace out there's a
pornography on the internet I don't want
you to know about that how do you access
no no you don't want to know about this
you've got work to do huh cannot beat